so dylan moore today getting the start
in right field
sweet miss got him first strikeout and
more
yeah we just saw it perhaps for the
first time ever
striking out and then bat flipping after
you strike out that's not how it's
supposed to work
but zolac does do a job he moves
shinsuchu over to third with one out for
willie calhoun
this ball hit high in the air deep out
to right field how will it carry into
the corner
it's off the wall and headed back
towards center field
one run is in calhoun heading to third
they're just getting to the baseball
they'll throw up the stop sign at third
base
willie calhoun with a triple and the
rangers lead one nothing
justin the sign from nola here's the
pitch the gallows swing and a line shot
diving catch by
j.p crawford on the right side of the
infield holy smokes they had their shift
on
crawford was well on the other side of
second base flying to his right robbing
gallow of a base hit
for the second out of the inning and jp
crawford
saves a run right there what a play by
crawford
ogleback is able to move into third base
so two outs
and the mariners have a runner 90 feet
away for the first time tonight
here comes dylan moore
the other way base hit we got a tie ball
game bogey's going to walk home won one
game dylan moore another rbi his seventh
nice job a good good battle won by
dylan moore halloween had a triple in
the first inning
there goes solac the pitch is a high
strike the throw goes into center field
solac will hop up and head to third base
so a steal of second the throwing error
by nola
gives solace third base but dick solak
sees the ball right away and he's up and
gone to third
calhoun in the air out to center field
and that one hauled in by lewis
but solace able to tag he'll score
easily on the sac fly and it's two to
one ranger
he has not yet walked to hitter probably
not with three balls might not be the
right time to
make that observation there's a ground
ball diving stop at third by kiner
falefa
hops up nice throw to first and they get
nola
one away another great defensive play
by isaiah kinder follefa and you see the
excitement from todd frazier he also
made a nice play on the other end of
this
oh another blast down to third and
another terrific play by connor falefa
gone wow not bad for a former catcher as
we watch
isaiah connor falefa continue to show
off the hands
two base runners out there now as you
get to the heart of the order kyle lewis
is two for two
the 01 pitch the lewis on the way
breaking ball swing and a fly ball
deep into left center field going back
on the run as solac to the wall reaches
up
and this one is gone goodbye baseball
kyle
lewis with his fourth home run of the
season
holy smokes drives in three and the
mariners now have the lead
four to two over the texas rangers rbi's
number
11 12 and 13 on the year
for the kid from snellville georgia what
a start for lewis
arkit will take over here in the top
half of the sixth inning the mariners
have two
on with only one out and lead the
rangers by a score of four to two
he swings and grounds it up the middle
it's into center field for a base hit
lopes rounds the bag at third and scores
crawford advances into second dylan
moore wasting no time
jumping on the first pitch he drives in
his second run of the night and it's
five two mariners in the sixth inning
one out of the bags packed in the sixth
inning
and very happy no doubt with the man
they have coming to the plate and kyle
seeger
chance for his fifth career grand slam
the one
swinging a high fly ball carry now to
right field gallow is back
leaping gone grand slam kyle seeger
the fifth of his career and kyle seeger
brings them all home
he has blown this game open in the sixth
inning it's nine
to two mariners steps dylan moore
center field and that thing's out of
here
oh my goodness he's got some pop fourth
home run
his third rbi tonight gives him nine
and the mariner league they got double
digits it's 10-2
seattle and there's two outs for the
rangers here in the bottom half of the
ninth inning that'll bring up designated
hitter willie calhoun
calhoun line drive and that's a wrap
as evan white gloves it and the mariners
win in resounding fashion
10-2 in game one down in texas and
congratulations to justin dunn
it's his first major league win